hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play afraid of monsters okay we're
gonna do she but ah there we go do I get
to drive a car that would be awesome
yes Hot Diggity don't tell me this is
the end of the game it's way too early
to be the end of the game good bear not
be
wait don't tell me it's the end of the
game things haven't even gotten really
weird yet so no way
come on now
Oh
forgive you why
you really should drive in you know your
lane I don't know what country you're in
Sweden or something your lane
okay
okay that was weird
where the heck did I just appear how the
heck did I get here okay so I best go
right oh that does okay ah no this way
laughs ah no no no no oh my god was
wrong with your hands
[ __ ] out of haha what that why didn't I
reload ah walking all funky Gary oh okay
got that there's a button or something
stop I stopped
battery load yellow-green okay
ah okay
ah this way left that way ah ah yeah
yeah yeah yeah ah running out of ammo
pills
I need pills need a button
I need a button button do why am I here
how did I get here ah this looks like
the beginning
Oh
are you doing their bunk oh god damn it
okay okay oh I can't do it I can't
oh [ __ ] you does four hits from full to
dead that's all it takes
I can't spend the ham oh okay just go
around you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you yes I am
going in the exact same direction what
the hell
right then I went that way
then I went left Oh No damn it it hit me
[ __ ] you okay this looks better jump
drop it up up job ah
not again don't have the ammo for this
I'm going the way you're telling me to
go I'm out of ammo I'm out I'm gone it
is I'm empty
how the [ __ ] do you expect me to survive
again hell I go this way will it just
drop me yeah it will okay I can't I
can't do that because I literally won't
be able to do
I can't I mean I swear I'm going the way
it's telling me apparently that's not
good enough
Oh ah what the hell okay so instead of
going this way I went
I went this way instead but then that
even that led me to
crazy place and instead of going that
way I should probably go that way and
then look there Why What Oh [ __ ] hell
okay not left there back oh this is just
me it's all [ __ ] around with you okay
so my epic memory serves
right there dodge the monster go this
way turn left right dog to the monster
get hit by the monster cuz I'm a
terrible player but this way turn left
here dodge [ __ ] hell
of course pizza [ __ ] [ __ ] and
what just yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] ah this Dodge
[ __ ] yo what the hell
ah come on [ __ ] off
no [ __ ] you
save it
[ __ ] you save it again
[ __ ] EU I'm dodging but I'm also saving
and I'll [ __ ] you sir even one more time
okay maybe I was supposed to look at the
signs as if they were standing on level
ground which means go right here which
means go backwards I don't know [ __ ]
I don't know ah okay bunch this one
would be straight to go left dodge that
turn around go right that way I don't
know save
this way
okay yes oh thank you oh but I have no
ammo damn I've crashed big heart
what were you asleep oh really what how
what the hell where were you driving
from Oh messed up oh no it's the forest
oh no oh no oh no
oh hell
ah [ __ ] hell
oh I'm gonna run that battery huh let me
in let me in oh [ __ ] uh-oh here we go
all this looks welcoming warm dark light
for our porch okay maybe there's some
ammo in here yes please thank you Paul
that's nothing right oh that's a
difficulty ah there we go
it's weird that they would have that
button to do that on their coffee table
why am I the only one to find that
strange oh why am I going upstairs why
am I going upstairs hello
shotgun well I am almost out of ammo so
I might as well good we have something
okay this looks familiar
this does look like something from graph
here okay so the light does do work in
this house patterns yes
what was that
okay leave me to my boxes go do your
thing
oh I'm at a hundred percent help amazing
incredible outstanding okay whoa who's
there
ah
oh it said look up and said outdoors
outdoors look up
I don't need more pills apparently
outdoors look up what am I supposed to
see
got a shotgun ah what was that I saw
something
Oh
ah where'd you come from where do you
all come from Oh screw you who you who
you who you where am I going
what am I where am I going where am I
good Oh where'd you come from
pulls let me out let me out let me out
let me let me let me was that ah where
we are huh what bullet gimme gimme
ah nah yeah mm did that was that it is
that ah ah
I had full health I had full full health
full health I had it I did you all saw
it
Boyle I don't anymore
what was the point of that what's the
point of that just besides me getting
myself hurt
is there no point there no pouring okay
their pills upstairs I get here yeah
okay outside look up I said that the
clue I'm supposed to get outside ah ah
just glad I'm finally able to one shot
it's like killing a witch you look up
see anything else pertinent oh what's
this a laundry room
whoa ah okay
it's okay I'm just a little jumpy that's
all another one anymore I get up there
look up I see nothing is that it there
had to be something else I mean there's
got to be can't be just boxing me into
this part of world
I don't see anything else so maybe I can
get out a second-story window and climb
up on something I don't know maybe I
gotta go back out there I don't know you
made every other room in the house why
not why leave this one jam donut
okay all right I don't see it unless
it's just too obvious to see which can
happen I suppose or whatever okay where
did I come from over there yeah whoa
this is different okay
ha whoops I missed terribly on that one
off fun oh yeah there we go okay this is
a brick wall nope uh-uh can't see over
it can't do anything about look up nope
nothing that's so hard to see be
everything because it's like everything
looks the same
everything's just the same pastel color
it was back here just back where my car
was
probably
yeah okay this is back where my car was
going this way come to the house laying
out a flashlight battery around the
house that's a tree not a zombie I
almost shot it ah [ __ ] hell yeah I
don't see anything else because this is
where that gate was and as far as I
could tell there was nothing to the gate
this er was something look up ah look up
ah okay I gotcha
why not knock these down do I have to
shoot it there we go
come here Oh nope crazy physics
seriously half-life was not theirs bad
was it I hope not
cuz my memory serves AK was a good game
this is physics uh Bob mediocre da Terra
bad game okay I'm just gonna push it
this way
we go we go this way then that way
AHA to get over the wall perfect very
pleased what that what da hell alright
actually this is gonna have to wait
until next time I'm all out of time
thank you guys so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
part bye-bye